disons qu'il ya un discours prometteurs
du premier ministre qui aborde pour moi
les vrais sujets qui font aujourd'hui
blocage dans le système de santé
mais comme il l'a dit lui même c'est
lancement du chantier de transformation
il ya une clause de revoyure au mois de
mai pour annoncer des réformes plus
précise en tout cas le diagnostic est
bon les sujets pointé sont bons le fait
de ne pas considérer que l'hôpital mais
de regarder l'ensemble du système de
santé c'est aussi positif parce qu'il y
avait le risque sinon de focaliser
uniquement sur j'allais dire peut-être
ceux qui font le plus parler d'eux les
hospitaliers mais néanmoins c'est
l'ensemble du système qui est touchée
aujourd'hui
et puis la dernière chose se donnait
aussi un calendrier serré trois mois
s'est aussi tourné le dos à ce qu'on a
peut-être connu par le passé de grandes
concertations qui sont envoyées aux le
calendes grecques pour les réformes on
renvoie les oui il ya urgence mais dans
les chantiers qui ont été annoncés il ya
des choses qui peuvent être à effet
immédiat sur la simplification sur les
premières mesures de financement
réorienter vers les actes
les verts la pertinence des actes ça
c'est des champs de la relance de
l'investissement spitalier ça c'est des
choses qui peuvent commencer à se
concrétiser dès 2018 et des choses
évidemment de beaucoup plus long terme
parce que le système auspices de système
de santé c'est un paquebot
évidemment on le réoriente pas du jour
au lendemain donc il ya des voilà il ya
des mesures intéressantes
encore faut-il qu au mois de mai le
gouvernement soit au rendez vous